hey you guys
time for the flickers of fear show these
are my horror movie reviews
the one we have today this is so random
you guys like how i ended up watching
this one
because you know how there's like a
million
million horror movies and a lot of them
are on 2b amazon prime netflix you know
it's like i have pretty much
all of the streaming services hulu
whatever
and there's so many movies on there and
it's really really hard to
sort through good ones bad ones you know
what i mean just because there's so many
you don't have like
several lifetimes to watch them all so i
had seen
this particular movie which is called
look away and i had seen it while i was
scrolling through
i think i originally saw it when i was
scrolling through the horror movies on
2b
and then i saw it on the free to me like
section on amazon prime as well
and i didn't really think that much
about it like i kind of thought you know
the poster looked kind of cool and stuff
but i didn't really think about it
so then one day i'm on in my youtube
recommendations i'm subscribed to this
one horror channel like he reviews
movies and it's called drum dumbs and he
had actually made a video about this
movie
and he's like why isn't anybody talking
about this because it's really really
good
and then i was like well you know maybe
i should put that on my list because it
looked kind of decent like the way he
talked when he showed the trailer and he
talked about what it was about i was
like that sounds actually uh pretty cool
so i decided to sit down and watch it
and you know what it was pretty damn
good and it's just like i really like
when
[ __ ] like that happens like when you
just kind of come across this random ass
movie
that maybe wouldn't get seen the weird
thing about this movie too
is that if you look it up on rotten
tomatoes
it only has i think 12 critic reviews
and it has a 17 rating so they're
obviously like a lot of really negative
reviews
but the weird thing about it is that if
you go to like horror channels
on youtube like you know like i said
like drum dumbs or um
sinister cinema or something like that
it's like those reviews are actually
really really positive and most of the
other
horror blogs and things like that that
actually reviewed us and there weren't a
lot
pretty much all of those were actually
they're like yeah this is actually a
pretty solid
uh psychological thriller and i would
tend to agree this is actually a really
really good movie and it's kind of a
shame that it sort of
didn't really go anywhere you know what
i'm saying so this came out in 2018
uh it's canadian it was directed by
assaf bernstein who i think is israeli
and i don't know if it's his first
movie or not but it's actually like
really really accomplished it's got like
some kind of big
you know names in it now the main girl
that plays the main part maria
india eisley i had seen her before i
think she was in one of the underworld
movies and she's been in a couple other
movies as well so she's not you know
coming out of nowhere or anything her
dad is actually played by jason isaacs
in a really
super creepy kind of turn i'll get into
that in a little bit and
her mom is played by mira sorvino so
there are like some kind of big stars in
this
and i feel like it's sort of a shame
that it didn't really do better because
i feel like it deserved
a lot better than it got i suppose
because i guess it sort of got forgotten
about
so as i said this came out in 2018 now
what the story behind this i think
originally it was called behind the
glass
like when it was first reviewed or when
it first came out in festivals or
whatever
but then they changed it to look away
when it came out in late 2018
so at the center of it you have this
high school girl who's 17 or 18 years
old named maria
played by india eisley and she is
a really beautiful girl but she's real
um shy she's real introverted and she's
real bullied it's a very caring
situation
where pretty much everybody at the
school just thinks she's
a weirdo for whatever reason i mean you
can kind of see why because she's
you know like i said she's very shy she
doesn't really talk a lot she is like a
little
weird and keeps to herself a lot uh and
she also
seems to have although they never say
this outright but she does seem to have
uh maybe an eating disorder
uh because she's you know she doesn't
eat a lot and her mom's kind of always
on her case about it so there's that
whole situation
now she does have actually one friend
this sort of quintessential
beautiful blonde popular girl type but
again implication being that they've
been friends since they were kids
and it's almost kind of like i don't
want to say it's like a frenemy
situation but it's kind of like that
where i think like the popular girl just
sort of like tolerates her
and just has her around because
obviously her coolness or popularity is
not rubbing off on her friend in any way
shape or form
so it's that kind of situation going on
which like i said you know i've seen
that kind of situation play out in real
life so i kind of know
uh what they're getting at with that one
of the most [ __ ] up things about this
movie
is not just the bullying situation which
is terrible and there's actually like
one dude at school who's like this super
weird looking
and he has seemingly made it his mission
in life to make maria's life as
miserable as possible
and he goes like pretty far like he'll
do like some physical [ __ ] like you know
tripping her oh didn't mean to do that
and he's just kind of like always
wanting to humiliate her and [ __ ]
so there's that whole situation but even
worse than that
is the [ __ ] that she's dealing with at
home so her parents
are some of the most dysfunctional
people i've ever seen
on screen well i mean i don't want to
say that because i've seen some pretty
like [ __ ] up [ __ ]
but her dad in particular played by
jason isaacs he is so good in this he is
like so
[ __ ] creepy so her dad
is a plastic surgeon now her family are
like really really well off they live in
like this really gorgeous
like house but it's a really the one
thing about this movie is that it's
really
cold and it's really sterile and i think
like the cinematography of that like
does a good job
of conveying that how she doesn't really
have anybody that
cares about her in her life or at least
that's how she's perceiving it
and honestly it does kind of seem like
that just gotta say
uh but yeah her dad is a plastic surgeon
and his whole thing
is he is obsessed with perfection
so he it's very embarrassing to him
that his daughter is not good enough in
his eyes like she's not pretty enough
she's not
thin enough she's not popular enough uh
he thinks she's a weirdo and a screw-up
and he's kind of not shy about saying it
like to
his wife uh even when maria is an
earshot which like i said that's really
gonna [ __ ] up
a teenager hearing that from your own
[ __ ] dad like how messed up she look
at her look at her it's like she's got
problems and this is not the other thing
uh and it's really really messed up and
he's always kind of criticizing her
appearance even though she's a perfectly
beautiful
uh young woman and that probably is
contributing to
her not wanting to eat because maybe she
thinks oh i'm not thin enough i'm not
perfect enough and
it's really sad because she always seems
to be
wanting to be perfect and just failing
miserably and it's really like kind of
[ __ ] her up
her mom her dad is also like [ __ ]
around on the mom
because of course he is and uh the mom
sort of is
in denial she's kind of a pill popper
well it's not even from her point of
it's kind of like the the husband is
kind of like always going oh you're
hysterical here
take your xanax or whatever the [ __ ] and
uh so he's kind of keeping her a little
bit medicated
and the mom is also a little bit
delusional too because i think she's
she's uh you know the the dad is like
really really controlling
of both the daughter and the wife so i
think the wife is kind of
living in this fantasy world where this
dude is actually not a piece of [ __ ]
and actually does care about her and all
all she has to do is
you know just be perfect and be awesome
and all these other things and
you know it everything will sort itself
out and he'll love her again or whatever
so that's kind of kind of a sad thing to
like
see play out there's one really creepy
scene too like where she's kind of
trying to tell him that something is the
matter with the daughter which is true
and he just doesn't want to hear it
and he's like you know you're getting
hysterical here take your medication and
then
she lays down on the bed and he like
puts a
you know like a a mud mask or whatever
you know what i'm saying he puts that
like on her face
and i was just kind of like whoa that's
that says a lot like that's kind of
scene it's like here you're getting old
[ __ ] whatever
so he's like [ __ ] around with one of
his patients as well so you know we'll
get into that the interesting thing
about this movie
is that even though this is kind of like
a mirror image
evil twin type of movie but it takes a
really long time to
set up maria's life and all of these
characters
you know all of these people her friends
her family uh her
you know the bullies at school they kind
of set up this entire thing for almost i
think
pretty much like half the movie like
before you even get into the body
swapping or whatever it is
which i thought was a really good thing
to do because you really got a sense of
her character you really got a sense of
the family situation what she was
putting up with
and you got a sense of why she maybe
needed this thing to happen and like i
said it leaves it ambiguous and i'll get
into that in a minute like whether
she's just imagining it imagining it all
or if it's like supernatural or whatever
so
you know i don't really want to spoil
too much about it but this is one of the
ones where
it's like it doesn't have a big twist or
anything like that so it's not like it's
gonna ruin your enjoyment of the movie
or anything like that if i tell you some
of the [ __ ] that happens in it
so about at the halfway point of the
movie maria finds
like it's kind of like tucked behind a
mirror she sees like a little piece of
a corner piece of paper or something
sticking out from behind the mirror and
she pulls it out and it's a sonogram
photo of twins now from
this and a couple of sort of weird dream
sequences
that the mom has you're led to believe
that maria maybe had a twin in the womb
that was born deformed or there was
something wrong with her and
perhaps the dad euthanized the kid
because it wasn't perfect
we don't know if that's really what
happened but that's kind of what's
implied you know what i'm saying so
maria finds this and shortly after
finding this photo
her reflection in the bathroom mirror
starts to do different [ __ ] to what
she's doing
so you know obviously this freaks her
the [ __ ] out as it would
but after a bit this reflection starts
talking to her
and says that her name is arum which is
maria spelled backwards
and she basically so so her and aaron
on the other side of the mirror aaron is
kind of everything that maria isn't
she's very confident she's very um
you know she's very sexual she's kind of
a wild child and [ __ ] like that
and she is pretty much like you know you
know who i am i've been here the whole
time i've seen everything that's
happened to you
and she kind of like gives this litany
of all these things that happened to
maria when she was younger
that maria had tried to forget about
because they were humiliating or
whatever and she's like i remember every
single thing
nobody really cares about you but me and
um you know all you have to do is let me
out of here
and you know i'll fix things that's what
she keeps saying
so for a long time maria is just kind of
wigged out but then
you know aaron starts kind of working on
her like some terrible things happen to
maria
um you know she gets humiliated by a
friend she gets really humiliated like
at the prom like i said again like kind
of like carrie not
not the same exact thing but a similar
kind of uh situation
at that point she says okay uh you know
me and you can trade places
and you can come out and so she has to
like kiss her through the mirror
and then at which point maria becomes
arum
and aaron starts taking horrible
horrible revenge
on all of the people that have [ __ ]
over maria in her life
including her best friend who like i
said is kind of a taunt
uh all the bullies at school also uh
gets with
the the twans boyfriend who maria had
had a crush
on and so she kind of fixes stuff but
she also kind of [ __ ] things up
one thing i will note is that even
though maria is now trapped behind the
glass she's now trapped behind the
mirror and now just has to like watch
all of the [ __ ] that aram is doing
and she gets like kind of upset about it
like you know
obviously [ __ ] like you know aram kills
uh the best friend
well she doesn't kill her directly she
just like
engineers it sort of so that there's an
accident and then
the friend ends up dying so you know
what i mean and i can see how that would
be upsetting and stuff but
the people in maria's life are so shitty
that you don't really feel all that bad
which i don't know it's i guess because
like i said you're seeing things from
maria's point of view so i guess that's
kind of what it'd be like but when she
actually sees the ship playing out
because that's the thing when aaron is
out doing whatever
as long as there is a reflective surface
somewhere
she can see what aaron is doing and vice
versa like when they were on the other
side of the mirror
so she basically goes around this whole
entire time
and fixes things and you know [ __ ] up
people that
you know did shitty stuff and needed to
be [ __ ] up and you know and it just
kind of goes from there
now like i said this movie it's a
psychological thriller it does have some
gore in it
um you know people's throats get slashed
people's heads get smashed you know [ __ ]
like that so it's not it's like a
slasher movie or anything but
it kind of gave me a little bit of a
black swan kind of vibe
sort of thing too but like it's like i
said sort of an evil twin thing
but i think it was kind of cool that
they left it ambiguous
as to whether maria like
is this a real supernatural thing did
maria really have a twin
that her dad essentially killed because
she
because the baby was deformed or
whatever and she has some kind of like
weird memory of that
um you know or now that's like her ghost
or whatever like behind the mirror it's
like something supernatural is going on
or is she just perceiving that
this is her like her alter ego and now
she's taken on
so it's still her but she's like taking
on the you know the opposite
of herself like she becomes her evil
twin and they kind of leave it ambiguous
as to which one of those that is
which i think was like kind of a good i
think it was a good
um choice because it could kind of go
either way and the last scene i thought
was kind of cool because she actually
she doesn't do anything bad to her mom
because her mom you know
her mom didn't do anything like directly
bad to her she was just kind of weak and
[ __ ] like that now she does expose her
dad's
affair like to the mom so to kind of you
know bust the mom out of her complacency
or whatever it's like hey look
you know dad's a piece of [ __ ] like
cheating on you and he's doing all these
other things
so kind of makes her face reality and
she doesn't like it but
in a lot of ways the stuff that aaron
does even though she's kind of like the
evil twin probably kind of needed to be
done i'm not saying she should go around
like murdering people and stuff but
like i said some of the people are so
shitty that you really didn't feel all
that bad about it
so you know what i mean but some of the
stuff she did was actually probably good
um and she was kind of upfront and
honest about things and like opened up
lines of communication that probably
needed to be opened up so
it's kind of like yeah it you know it
kind of could go either way is it good
is it bad
it was kind of both things but yeah so
like the last scene is just kind of like
[ __ ] like i said she doesn't do anything
to the mom the mom was just weak she
didn't do anything
you know terrible and uh the the last
scene is kind of like
you know a mirror and it's like uh the
mom and then
you know the maria is on one side and
then it keeps flipping back and forth
and like
arum's on this side and then it's kind
of like then there's both of them so
it's almost kind of like
at the end they were both sort of
brought together
you know what i mean and now they're
like one person now they're like a whole
person
but yeah so basically like i said this
movie
it seemed like it came out late 2018
it's a canadian film
kind of went nowhere uh got like really
bad reviews from
cr like general critics but it seemed
like most of the horror critics that i
read that had seen it um actually really
dug it and i really dug it too it was
like it
looked really cool the cinematography
was gorgeous it was very cold very snowy
um very sterile and i think that was
like a really good
um kind of look for it to have it really
gave it like a
like a mood and everything uh but yeah
it's
i definitely would recommend checking
out if you like psychological thrillers
like evil twin kind of [ __ ]
really well done all the uh performances
are good the dad in this played by jason
isaacs is super super [ __ ] creepy i
mean he decides he's gonna give
maria like a facelift for her birthday
like her 18th birthday
that she thought she was gonna get a car
and then he's like no we gotta fix
your ears they kind of stick out too
much and your nose will make it longer
and all this other stuff and i'm just
like oh my god
it's like so [ __ ] up and it's like
there's some kind of weird they don't go
super into this but there is some kind
of like weird psychosexual
stuff going on there because i think the
dad's kind of into the daughter and i
don't know it's like really really
creepy
but yeah so if you like psychological
thrillers
this is kind of one that flew under the
radar and i feel like more people should
see it because it's actually
it's pretty [ __ ] good i mean i
thought it was pretty damn good for
being
you know for kind of coming out of
nowhere and me just like hearing about
it
randomly uh but yeah it's on 2b if you
want to watch it for free
and if you have amazon prime you can
also watch it for free on there it might
be on sm
it might be on hulu too now that i'm
thinking about it but yeah i would
definitely recommend uh
checking out i i really dug it and you
may too
so let me know if you've seen it and
tell me your thoughts about it in the
comments
and i will see you on the next one bye